Um, okay, let's see who's next here.
Let's go to the seven, seven, four area code.
Who's calling seven seven four.
Could be a local viewer.
You know, you never know who's calling in
from seven, seven, four today.
Hey David, this is cliff.
I'm from what's there?
Hey cliff, what's going on?
Hey Od, nothing.
How are you?
Good.
Um, so I was just wondering, I've been watching
a lot of anger, danger gang.
Yup.
And, um, so I was just wondering what's your
take, do you think that socialism makes people
more sociable?
Uh, I think that's a very, very silly question.
Well, I'm, I'm just wondering just because
in general, you, you got all the money out
there and then more people, you know, they
can talk, they can exchange.
Does socialism make people more social?
That's the question.
Yes.
And what does that have to do with Andrew
Yang?
Um, well, you know, he's always accused of
being a socialist, but
really who accused the end of being a socialist?
I've seen him.
It'd be accused of being a libertarian.
Yeah.
I mean, I mean, yeah, people, not to say uneducated
people, but people just, their first, their
first assumption of him is generally, you
know, his, he's always attacked as a socialist.
I've not seen that once.
Like who's an example of a person who did
that?
Oh, you haven't?
Oh I um, well I mean when he was, um, I think
it was Fox News.
I don't remember the exact name of the anchor,
but, um, I know one of them said, and I know
he directly studies that, come on, you're
smarter than that, you know, you know that
this isn't socialism.
Oh, okay.
Yeah.
Maybe that was like Stuart Varney or Neil
Kabuto or something like that when Yang talked
about ubi.
Listen, I think that absolutely, socialism
makes people much more social and it would
just improve everybody's dating and, and personal
lives and friendships.
I think that's a really, really insightful
question.
Okay.
Thank you.
All right.
Very, very good.
Thank you.